so republican texas senator ted cruz
continues to say almost downright
sinister things about gun safety most
recently saying that if there were no
guns in america
the number of murders would actually go
up huh how is that possible we'll talk
about it here's the clip ted cruz on his
i guess he has a podcast now called
verdict it's a very weird and deranged
program but let's listen to what ted
cruz had to say see if you can make
sense out of this
taking away every firearm that michael
knowles owns would not have stopped this
psychopath
from murdering children in uvalde
and by the way we see that
in chicago and new york and dc and
california where they have very strict
gun control yeah and the criminals still
have guns
and still carry out murders if you could
wave a magic wand
and eliminate all firearms in america
there would be substantially more
murders than there are today that is an
absolutely nutty comment if you could
wave a magic wand and eliminate all
firearms in america there would be
substantially more murders
think about it on an incident by
incident basis imagine
this particular shooter in texas
the shooter
maybe would have killed someone but the
odds are that without a gun he doesn't
kill nearly as many people i've never
heard of an incident to go back to our
earlier good liar segment where someone
kills 20 people with a hammer
i've never heard of an incident
in which police armed police
i assume in ted cruz's vision the police
still have firearms
where armed police don't go in to
confront a knife-wielding attacker for
80 minutes because they're afraid i've
just never heard of that now remember
we're doing imaginary stuff if you could
wave a wand and if waving the wand
actually eliminated all the firearms how
on earth would there be more murders it
is a logical impossibility
now it's also remember important to
remember
that the rate of firearm homicides per
hundred thousand people is off the
charts in the united states you look at
what we're putting this up this is from
the ihme
in the us
the rate of firearm homicides per
hundred thousand people is just over
four
you then have chile just under two
and then a whole bunch of countries at
either 0.5 or lower you know a lot of
these places
uh but spain is
0.13 firearm homicides per hundred
thousand people the uk which has very
strict gun control
0.04 firearm homicides per 100 000
people the major difference is we have
the most guns now do a lot of these
countries have better access to mental
health care yes many of them do
uh do do many of these countries not
have the toxic and depraved american
gulf gun culture yes many of them don't
have that
but the biggest difference is the number
of firearms in the civilian population
per capita
and you see
the
outcome of that in the rate of firearms
homicides and the major difference is we
have the most guns apply ted cruz's
logic to almost everything else well if
you eliminated all cars
you would end up with more traffic
fatalities well hold on how how would
that work that doesn't make any sense
maybe if you eliminated all cars you'd
end up with i don't know more deaths
from heart attack because there'd be no
vehicles to take people to emergency
rooms oh okay well
that's plausible and we could explore
whether it's true and much the same way
if you waived a magic wand and
eliminated all guns
maybe the number of murders from other
things would go up but relative to the
number of murders that can so easily be
done with high-powered firearms the
number of murders would certainly go
down and uh at this point they're just
they're not even thinking
realistically in any way they're just
they're just not it's just not it's not
we're not operating in the real world
anymore and they will say absolutely
anything